ardi soir sur tf1 il y avait un nouvel
épisode de koh lanta lé combat des héros
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
la première polémique c'est clémentine
qui trouve le collier d'immunité
la séquence qui a fait parler depuis
vendredi dernier c'est celle où
clémentine donc trouve ce collier elle
s'est mise en tête d'en trouver un qui
est elle a très vite trouvé ça
d'ailleurs scandalisé les internautes du
genre tiens c'est marrant tu regardes
koh lanta toni ou pas non tu le ferais
ou pas franchement koh lanta c'est un
truc qui m'a toujours intéressé mais moi
j'aime bien manger tard koh-lanta
constat bien ouais moi j'adore koh lanta
mais j'ai un petit bémol en ce moment je
reviens un petit peu moins je trouve
qu'ils parlent trop fort hills et bavard
salut à toi même mon gosse qui est petit
lait mais au début on audio non il parle
trop les gens non sérieusement on veut
voir un petit peu d'épreuves quand même
à raison de la fraude stratégie voilà
les stratégies c'est bien un e d'un
moment ailleurs je vais dire ça a perdu
encore 400 mille téléspectateurs
s'affaisser descendu sous la barre des 5
millions c'est très très rare que colomb
tad descendre sous la barre des 5
justement je pense que c'est beaucoup
aimé mais je vous dire quand même dans
un monde où il fait beau regarder ce qui
a scandalisé les internautes
la seule solution pour m'en sortir je me
dis j'ai de trouver ce photocall et donc
vous allez faire un petit tour dans la
plaine par là bas
je suis appelé je ne sens pas un endroit
j'ai trouvé opposé
mais j'y crois je mette dans le ski
intention d'avoir un champion eurocup
non ça fait quatre ans non je vais le
cachet assez vite à l'est et donc sur
les réseaux sociaux comme par hasard
elle trouva collier nous prennent
vraiment pour des cons c'est trop
scénarisé jose à koh lanta
alors comme ça au moment où clémente il
se sent en danger et de se faire
éliminer elle trouve le collier vous ne
prenez pour des cons parce que grâce au
collier d'immunité
clémentine a pu sauver sa place au
détriment de tiffany wii nommé frank a
raison ça devienne la télé réalité dans
la boue alors ça pleure ça couine sa
part on est dans une halte garderie
c'est insupportable s'énerve rg pas là
bas j'ai pas trop oui ça parle trop loin
qu'à brasser des preuves
voilà oui mais oui mais si surtout je
m'excuse mais elle m'a dit pose une
question à chaque fois c'est à dire que
parce que quand même faut qu'ils aient
ils vont faire caca oui donc quand ils
partent que les autres se disent tiens
il a cherché un collier d'immunité
pouvoir dire non non non je suis
quelqu'un j'ai pas succession des mois
qui se passe sur kaka c'est sur m6
émission bien on les voit pas bien fermé
on est dans un monde où tout le monde
fait caca parfois même à koh lanta
sophie gagnon peut-être au hainaut
annonce la malheureuse
oui oui c'est évidemment bidonné lente
il a maintenant je vais dire je somme la
productrice de kolontar alexia
laroche-joubert de venir faire alexia
oui mais qu'elle vienne s'expliquer ici
l art du mime et ils ont elles répondu à
l'envoi des sous-fifres qu'elle vienne
en personne résidant répondu aujourd'hui
en 210 et voilà c'est dit croyant qu'est
ce qu'ils ont dit ils ont dit que
effectivement ont elles dit qu'elle veut
trouver un collier puis cinq minutes
après dans l'émission dans le montage de
l'émission la voix trouver le collier
mais qu'en réalité ils ont tourné des
heures et concert oui je vais vous
donner en fait ce qui se passe dans koh
lanta et dans beaucoup de sud aventure
en fait où l'alors la nuit ce silent
hill ans quand il entre confidences une
chasse il ya des cadreurs qui sont
positionnés je publie à une chose c'est
que normalement un candidat qui est un
petit peu ce malin malin et habitué des
repères où sont les cadreurs et
solitaire la zone est plutôt par là
wroclaw toujours bien passé bientôt ils
vont mettre les cogner sur les calories
un petit peu con ils sont pas ils sont
pas 18 donc qu'il est candidat il ya où
il ya au moins aux 10-14 contre balancer
sur la fin par personne pour au moins
que ça fasse pas tiens ils me suivent
sur une barre je pense pas un parti mais
on en fait 100 par personne alors il
sait pas c'est autre chose c'est que les
rouges arrêtait pas de gagner des lots
qu'ils ont refait les équipes regardent
alors ça ça sans mandat ni sa scandalisé
les zidane vous gagnez bravo et je vous
ai parlé d'un avantage très conséquent
et pour nous qui terminait deuxième
yacine d'un avantage conséquent nous
annoncent officiellement vous êtes les
capitaines des deux nouvelles équipes
que vous allez constituer ou les deux
je pense que toutes les équipes où il ya
des liens il faut les séparer il ya de
la qualité dans les deux équipes donc je
vais d'abord commencé par des jeunes de
façon à couper l'herbe sous le pied a
dit van
je leur disais c'est devenu c'est devenu
on dirait que c'est dire que c'est moi
qui t'ai les avec n'importe quel iphone
york
ils sont réactifs pour moi on pouvait
pas les laisser aller dans le mur
9 4 5 de laisser continuer donc les
reproches de torquay son parent étoile à
la prince tant ils sont réactifs de l'am
show des d'audience et la police ont
censuré la production des spectateurs
qui est pris pour un con d'heure ça nous
arrange pas refait les équipes vous avez
pas vous engueuler à cause de koh lanta
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]